[Music]
all right we are only nine weeks away
from the midterm races and key senate
matchups now are beginning to take shape
republicans now are on the rise that
includes in georgia herschel walker
polls now have this race neck and neck
the last two polls have herschel up over
raphael warnock and the senate may very
well be decided by the state of georgia
by the way incumbent senator rafael
warnock has agreed to finally debate
herschel walker an offer in savannah
that was made that'll happen in october
and here's the latest ad from the walker
campaign laying out just what is at
stake in the great state of georgia take
a look
i do absolutely agree that it's racist
it is a redux of jim crow in a suit and
tie america has a long history of
systemic racism you ain't black america
has a pre-existing condition it's called
racism
senator warnock believes america is a
bad country full of racist people
i believe we're a great country full of
generous people
one ought wants to divide us
i want to bring us together i'm a
herschel worker i approve this message
i guess the polls are bringing out the
senate candidates for the democrats
because uh in pennsylvania tonight john
fetterman has now agreed to debate dr
amon oz so will the phony spoiled
socialist trust fund brat no hoodie is
he going to follow through
and by the way for both states debates
need to take place before a single vote
is even cast that's only fair for voters
here now is georgia senate candidate
herschel walker before i get to what
changed in the dynamics raphael warnock
supports court packing
an end to cash bail
he was involved in a youth camp kid
abuse scandal
didn't want the police to interview the
people involved he's praised farrakhan
he's praised reverend jeremiah wright
he's compared the police to thugs and
gangsters he wants to get rid of fossil
fuels he wants crt in our schools he
said the opioid crisis is only an issue
because it's impacting uh people that
are white and suburban
the guy also by the way has a problem
paying
neglecting his children and failing to
pay
child care expenses uh his ex-wife
claimed he ran over
uh her in a domestic dispute and i can
keep going on how how is this race even
close because the monitoring of media
down in georgia seems to have been
negative against you but now your
message seems to be penetrating with
recent polls what happened
well the reason why sean is i'm getting
out meeting the people and i'm talking
to the people and the people speaking
you know they've spent over 50 million
dollars against me
but the race is still tired i'm up by
one and the reason why is that people
want a change in washington senator
warnock is a cut from the claw for joe
biden and what i mean by that is he
believes in higher taxes he believes in
open borders he voted to put men and
women in sports and that's not what the
georgia people want majority people want
someone they can trust and they can
trust in herself walker so no matter
what he's not going to
talk anything the media is not going to
say anything positive about me but i've
done a lot of positive things he's done
a lot of negative things but let's not
talk about that let's talk about his
record as a senator as a senator he
hasn't done a good job and it's time for
someone else to take that seat back for
the people because that people belong to
the uh to that seat belong to the people
of georgia
what percentage of the time
does rafael warnock vote with chuck
schumer and with joe biden
it is 96 of the time 96 of the time and
and he don't even want to campaign with
joe biden now he's trying to distance
himself from it but he can't he can't
distance himself because he's he's just
like i said he cut from that same claw
for joe biden i've called him a wolf in
sheets clothing he pretends he's trying
to help you when he's there all the time
he's continuing to hurt you you've seen
that the people here are hurting from
the uh economy the people here are
hurting from the crime but yet he's
profited while he's been in office and
you know if if anyone is going to hurt
him
double does not the people that have put
you in office
he doubled his income herself oh no your
income as a politician
well and this is this is he's only been
in and watching for a little bit and now
his income has gone up and now you said
that he wanted to debate me but he
hadn't completely said he won a debate
he still have a couple of things he said
oh if you do this if you do that why
don't he just show up on october the
14th for a fair and equitable debate
that's about the people so the people
can see the contrast between the two of
us and i want people to continue
to continue to raise money
i want to know why
single voters cast with early voting
well i can tell you the reason why it's
like a game for them they've been
raising money and that's why i tell
people to go to
and let's raise this money so we can get
them into a debate because all they want
to do is put negative ads out there
because they can't win on the issues
they can't win on the issues and now
since they see that the pros are
changing they're being told by their
people hey you got a debate you got to
debate well he's still putting criteria
in it and i'm telling him to put his big
man pants on show up in savannah georgia
on october 14th let's debate and people
can see the contrast we've seen between
the two of us
well the only problem is with these late
debates a lot of people will have voted
by that that's to me is a problem i
think debates should take place before a
single vote is cast
but i will be watching we are looking
forward to it congratulations on your
recent poll
surging i think this could be the race
that decides the balance of power in the
senate herschel we wish you the best